le savoir faire des artisans
d'ile-de-france mise à l'honneur à jouy
en josas textile papier bois céramique
métal des matières travaillées pour
fabriquer ces 24 création présentée au
musée de la toile de jouy
[Musique]
on
une exposition dans le cadre du concours
régional ateliers d'art de france avec
deux catégories il ya un prix création
donc ça concerne toujours des savoir
faire qui sont des savoir faire
traditionnels souvent en france et puis
il ya un prix patrimoine qui a été
décerné et là ça s'adresse plutôt à des
spécialistes de la restauration d'objets
lauréats du concours création car maslow
avec honte grise un travail sur des
métaux et pierres précieuses pour
fabriquer un bijou dans la catégorie
patrimoine
anahit flegme a été désigné pour texaco
une fabrication de plusieurs reliure
brodé
en fait les deux lauréats qui ont été
choisis outre la paire fait maîtrise de
leur registre de leur métier
ce qui nous a vraiment impressionnés
c'est leur démarche
ce sont des gens qui vont très très loin
dans leurs recherches
les deux lauréats d'île de france vont
être invités à un salon international à
l'automne 2020 avant la remise des prix
nationaux dans les deux catégories
jusqu'au 8 septembre les 24 pièces
restait exposée au musée de la toile de
jouy